Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonsoir
après demain dans deux pays séparés par
quelques 20000 km vont se dérouler des
élections générales il suffit de
connaître les noms de ces pays pour
comprendre que ces scrutins ne peuvent
pas nous Français nous laisser
indifférent il s'agit du Vietnam et du
Portugal le Vietnam ancienne colonie
française ou des milliers de français
sont morts dans un combat sans espoir
précurseur de milliers d'Américains le
Vietnam aujourd'hui aux mains des
communistes qui organise ces élections
générales que ce peuple attend depuis
toujours mais quelles élections le
Portugal délivrait il y a deux ans d'une
dictature cinquantenaire qui serait
tombée lui aussi quelques mois plus tard
comme un fruit mûr aux mains des
communistes sans un ultime sursaut du
Parti socialiste du Portugal nous
envoyer spéciaux nous ont fait parvenir
un reportage qui illustre bien les
incertitudes qui pèsent sur l'avenir de
ce pays à 48 heures d'un scrutin qui
finalement intéresse toute l'Europe je
vous invite à suivre ce reportage que
nous diffuserons en conclusion de ce
journal mais tout de suite c'est par le
Vietnam que nous allons ouvrir grâce à
ces images exclusives filmées sur place
cette semaine par l'une de nos équipes
un an après la chute de Saïgon les
autorités révolutionnaires préparent la
population de chimie ville pour les
élections qui doivent concrétiser la
réunification
492 députés doivent être élus dans les
38 provinces du nouveau Vietnam
dans une atmosphère de kermesse des
voitures de propagande et des cortèges
parcourent la ville
il faut démontrer la valeur symbolique
de ces élections mais aussi apprendre à
la population la signification du
système particulier du scrutin par liste
si vous voyez la liste des candidats
à l'Assemblée nationale de la ville de
rotignies vous verrez que les candidats
sont d'origine de tous les milieux
il y a des vétérans des deux résistances
il y a des paysans des ouvriers des
intellectuels des religieux des jeunes
vous voyez bien que
ces candidats sont choisis par toutes
les
organisations politiques et de masse
le grand meeting de masse sont organisés
afin de confronter les postulants avec
la base de provoquer des questions et
des contestations et de discuter du
bien-fondé des candidatures en dernier
ressort c'est cependant le comité
révolutionnaire qui avalise les listes
proposées
dans le meeting de la circonscription de
Saigon où le président du GRP monsieur
win tanfat et Candida la question qui
lui était posée le plus souvent et celle
du chômage en effet un an après la
défaite de Thiou avec cette immense
armée en majeure partie rééduquer et
reconverti à la vie civile avec tous
ceux qui ne vivaient qu'en marge de
cette soldatesse et de la présence
étrangère de son commerce et de ses
plaisirs le Sud Vietnam compte
maintenant 3 millions et demi de
chômeurs
ce sera le problème majeur du nouveau
gouvernement du Vietnam réunifié pour
lequel les candidats à la nouvelle
Assemblée nationale doivent s'expliquer
et justifier leur programme
pouvez-vous madame bin définir la
position du Vietnam dans ses relations
futures avec les pays occidentaux
nous continuerons à
prendre position
c'est-à-dire à suivre une politique un
peu peur de la paix de l'indépendance
nationale de la démocratie et du progrès
social et sur la base de ces objectifs
nous vous souhaitons avoir des relations
normales avec les pays occidentaux tous
les pays occidentaux y compris les
États-Unis et également à l'eau
souhaitons que
nous aurons des relations de bonnes
relations de coopération économique et
commerciale avec tous ces pays
afin de
nous aider dans
notre tâche de la concession de notre
pays
un médicament utilisé fréquemment en
France émise aujourd'hui en accusation
il aurait tué un millier de japonais il
en aurait rendu un firme pour la vie 30
000 le produit de base le Clio qui neule
incriminé entre chez nous dans la
composition d'une douzaine de remèdes
certains sont en vente libre ils sont
utilisés notamment contre l'aérophagie
les troubles intestinaux lorsque nous
avons appris par la Fédération nationale
des coopératives de consommation les
ravages causés par cette substance au
Japon nous avons immédiatement enquêté
en France pour savoir à quoi s'en tenir
c'est le résultat de cette première
enquête que nous vous livrons ce soir je
vous le dis tout de suite elle est
instructive mais elle n'est pas
concluante
30000 infirmes un millier de morts le
Clio kinol est dangereux au Japon et il
est interdit en France on peut se le
procurer librement mais on en parle pas
jusqu'à ce que peut-être un patient
devienne victime les médicaments à base
de Clio quinol peuvent provoquer des
atteintes d'une érotique et une
paralysie partielle
et je considère que lorsqu'un produit
est toxique que se produit est interdit
dans des pays comme le Japon que son
usage est très strictement réglementé en
Norvège en Suède et aux États-Unis je
considère que laisser se produire en
vente libre pour certaines spécialité en
France c'est un acte criminel il y a peu
de médecins qui connaissent la réelle
gravité des accidents provoquaient par
l'équinoléon il y a peu de médecins qui
connaissent leur métier non mais il y a
une très mauvaise information sur les
médicaments en France et vous prenez un
dictionnaire comme le vital je n'ai là
que le Vidal 75 et vous apercevez qu'on
recommande un produit de cet ordre pour
traiter les diarrhées saisonnières alors
c'est exactement utilisé la bombe
atomique pour tuer une mouche évidemment
dans les dernières éditions du final on
parle de ces accidents nerveux et
oculaires
mais on n'est pas en garde le médecin
contre l'utilisation de ce type de
médicaments pour des affections banales
la multiplication des médicaments
nouveaux mis sur le marché peut être
ainsi responsable l'équilibre de la
valeur thérapeutique et de la toxicité
et parfois contestable mais ce qui est
plus grave c'est que l'on puisse
considérer qu'un produit dangereux pour
les japonais ne l'est pas pour les
Français et ne pas apporter plus de
protection plus d'informations aux
consommateurs ce produit est maintenant
théoriquement sur ordonnance
je dis théoriquement parce que
effectivement nous avons fait un petit
essai nous avons acheté une douzaine de
produits qui tousse renferme le principe
de base
vous avez 6 produits ici qui sont vendus
sur ordonnance
mais nous avons pu acheter 6 autres
produits ici sans ordonnance ils sont
donc en vente libre et vous pouvez les
acheter n'importe comment et les
utiliser pour une auto médication si on
supprimait tous les médicaments qui
lorsqu'ils sont pris à doses importantes
deviennent dangereux et bien je crois
que les médecins n'auraient plus rien
pour soigner les malades car je suis
certain et là je voyais vous je ne parle
pas sans peser mes mots qu'il y a eu
beaucoup plus de décès avec l'aspirine
qu'avec ce produit là
bien sûr n'importe quel produit est
dangereux à trop fortes doses mais la
réglementation en vigueur pour la
douzaine de médicaments contenant du
Clio kinol et bien légère car jusqu'à
présent personne n'a démontré qu'il n'y
avait pas danger surtout lorsque
l'utilisation du médicament est possible
sans le contrôle d'un médecin
le drapeau rouge flotte sur l'une des
universités parisiennes le centre
universitaire Jussieu l'un des hauts
lieux de la contestation étudiante ce
centre que dont nous voyons derrière
nous d'ailleurs l'une des façades il s'y
tenait aujourd'hui une réunion des
délégués des différents mouvements
contestataires très politisés si l'on en
juge par cet emblème c'est ce qu'on
appelle annoncé la couleur c'est
d'ailleurs à Jussieu que ce matin des
tracts étaient distribués aux étudiants
traquent dans lesquels des conseils
pratiques étaient donnés à ceux qui
entendaient manifester dans l'après-midi
comment s'habiller comment se protéger
des gaz lacrymogènes cette manifestation
une de plus s'est mise en branle vers
17h30 à partir de la place de la
Bastille à Paris
quand il est lycéens qui ont défilé cet
après-midi à Paris de la Bastille à la
place d'enfer Rochereau à coup sûr entre
15 et 20 000 dès le début de la
formation du cortège on a pu noter que
cette fois-ci les étudiants avaient pris
leur précaution pour éviter tout
débordement un service d'ordre important
et une nouvelle technique pour isoler
davantage les éléments incontrôlés cela
n'a pourtant pas empêché la formation de
groupuscules dans le défilé des
groupuscules qui ont provoqué quelques
échauffourés avec les forces de l'ordre
à la hauteur de la prison de la Santé
mais la dispersion semble à l'heure
actuelle bien se dérouler au-delà des
manifestations des regroupements et des
forums le problème est maintenant de
savoir ce que peuvent faire les
étudiants en fait la situation est
toujours bloquée et personne n'a pu
ignorer les déclarations d'hier du chef
de l'État qui réaffirmait qu'il serait
anormal que des grévistes obtiennent des
diplômes nous pensons monsieur Giscard
d'Estaing ne répond pas à la demande
massive des étudiants d'abrogation de la
réforme que Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing
prétendait établir une société de
libérale avancée même et que au
contraire il s'oppose à la majorité des
étudiants qui ne sont ni des gauchistes
que Bloody madame sognac ni simplement
des communistes comme le dit Monsieur
Chirac mais la masse des étudiants nous
considérons de notre côté que notre
mouvement depuis trois mois est un
mouvement de grève générale de
l'université un mouvement qui rejoint de
plus en plus par les enseignants mais
qui va continuer
il y a du nouveau ce soir dans la faire
à Gray cette affaire trouble les
Français toujours sensibles à l'erreur
judiciaire mais y a-t-il en l'occurrence
erreur judiciaire l'élément nouveau
c'est une déclaration de l'un des
co-écultés de Roland Agret Antoine
Santelli comparaissait devant la cour
d'appel de Dijon pour un délit
secondaire cet homme de 33 ans condamné
à la réclusion perpétuelle a dit et
répété avec un assistance devant la Cour
je déclare que Roland Agret est innocent
du crime pour lequel il a été condamné
par la Cour d'Assise du Gard les
assassinats que j'ai commis pour la
somme de 50000 francs ont été
commandités non pas par agrès mais par
le service d'action civique le sac un
autre coinculpé de Roland agréé avait
déjà dans une lettre au garde des sceaux
affirmait qu'elle Grey n'était pas
coupable du crime pour lequel il avait
été condamné la justice devra apprécier
la valeur de ces déclarations en
attendant agrêt transporter à l'hôpital
est alimentée de force par injection de
sérum à ce propos vous allez entendre
une déclaration celle du docteur se
lance Troisier inspecteur général de la
médecine pénitentiaire qui ne partage
pas le point de vue de la femme de
Roland agréé de ses défenseurs sur la
gravité de son état de santé
sont les tailles bon et il n'y a pas de
d'anomalies peut-être un peu de
potassium qui a été un petit peu qui a
été un peu diminué mais si vous voulez
du point de vue pratique biologiquement
il est équilibré c'est ce que je
souhaite et cet équilibre si vous voulez
a été maintenu grâce aussi au perfusion
et je tiens tout de suite à vous le dire
il a accepté ses perfusions on a
absolument pas obligé de le faire on ne
peut pas dire quand même qu'après 30
jours de greffe de la fin ils sont en
pleine forme
fragile c'est un équilibre qui est
extrêmement fragile qui peut se
détériorer mais si il accepte comme il
accepte en ce moment que nous le
soignons que nous apportions selon qu'il
a besoin et que en attendant la révision
de son procès ou que le procès soit
révisé ou qui est une décision mais ça
ce n'est pas du tout bon faite Mohamed
c'est en fait c'est de d'essayer
d'arriver si vous voulez de le maintenir
dans un équilibre à la fois clinique et
biologique qui soit valable de façon à
ce qu'ils prennent ces décisions quand
il aura à les prendre si la rencontre
est-ce qu'on peut vivre avec deux
fourchettes alors distinguer à vivre
avec des fourchettes si vous voulez on
le suit régulièrement on le passe à la
radio matin et soir pour voir où elles
sont est-ce qu'elles évoluent si vous
voulez ou est-ce qu'au contraire elle
risque de perforer un organe noble comme
nous disons l'estomac ou l'intestin et à
ce moment-là ce serait une indication
opératoire et nous sommes tout près
naturellement s'il le fallait à l'opérer
vous qui avez l'habitude de ce genre de
problème en tant qu'inspecteur général
de la médecine pénitentiaire est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il y a dans la démarche
d'agrès à certains courages
pour pouvoir arriver à rester pendant
tant de temps sans manger je ne sais pas
si vous et moi nous pourrions le faire
mais ça si vous voulez ce n'est pas mon
problème mon problème c'est d'essayer
d'essayer de lui faire comprendre qu'il
vaut mieux qu'il soit en bonne forme en
meilleure forme qui n'est à l'heure
actuelle pour affronter peut-être des
décisions qui leur a affronté plus tard
donc comme annoncé en début de ce
journal rendons-nous maintenant au
Portugal ou après-demain les électeurs
vont élire des députés deux ans après la
révolution qui a mis fin à 50 années de
dictatures deux ans de soubresauts
d'incertitude de crise économique que
sera le Portugal d'après les élections
voici ce que nous envoyait spéciaux ont
vu et entendu dans le sud du pays
un peu majeur Thomson un peu cadet de
Gascogne c'est Georges vanzeller le nom
sonne étrangement flamand dans la laine
tes jours ce Sud profond du Portugal
il incarne trois siècles d'aristocratie
terrienne et féodale le clan van Zeller
une vingtaine de cousins qui régnaient
sur 7000 hectares d'Olivier le
chêne-liège de terre à blé sans compter
les espaces laissés en friche pour les
plaisirs de la chasse
et puis c'est le coup de tonnerre du 25
avril 74 la dictature mise à bas la
révolte paysanne les expropriations qui
frappent les grands propriétaires
l'attribut vanzeller et laminées seul
Georges s'accroche
je suis opposé tout le temps j'ai eu
deux attaques ici
et le premier c'était en pleine période
borchevique quand ça arrive ce qu'on
appelle
goncerviste vous êtes défendu les armes
à la main oui oui j'avais un petit
dispositif monté et
ça a marché
avec ces deux tracteurs et 9 ouvriers
agricoles il exploite 600 hectares le
dixième de l'ancien patrimoine familial
autour de lui à perte de vue des
coopératives agricoles et des fermes
collectives
et comme vous pouvez voyez
voir tous ces
occupés
on est dans une île
cerclé par les bons chimiques ils ont
tout caché la balle les
autres choses des cultures des parce que
leur place et de détruire
à l'avant guardiale première ferme
collective de laine séjour le spectacle
de ces femmes aux champs ne correspond
pas à l'apocalypse décrit par Georges
vanzeller
pourtant il y a eu des excès des
occupations illégales des spoliations de
petits agriculteurs au point que
beaucoup de paysans surtout dans le nord
du Portugal souhaite ouvertement
aujourd'hui la défaite de la gauche aux
élections
ici dans le sud il y a eu trop de
misères et d'oppression dans le passé
les cols causes à la portugaise ont
transformé en salariés des hommes et des
femmes qui étaient au chômage de 6 à 8
mois par an
sans ressources c'est à dire livré au
bon vouloir des grands propriétaires
elle ferait tout pour rendre les terres
aux gens propriétaires ce qui n'irait
pas sans de la violence et de la
répression toute façon moi je suis
optimiste je suis convaincu Parti
socialiste va gagner les élections donc
que les grandes propriétaires ne
retrouveront pas les privilèges l'avant
le 25 avril et qu'on poursuivra la
réforme agraire
le langage du ministre socialiste de
l'agriculture c'est celui que tient
Alvaro cunial devant les auditoires
villageois du Sud
la ligne pour les communistes c'est une
chasse étroitement gardée une baronie à
l'abri expertise de l'hérésie
conservatrice
tant même sur cette terre d'élection
révolutionnaire les parties de droite
viennent aujourd'hui narguer le PC
dans les arènes de la capitale de la
Nintendo la Mecque rouge du Portugal ils
ont organisé récemment un meeting
l'assistance était maigre il est vrai et
protégé par un service d'ordre
impressionnant unité de choc de la
police militaire casquée gendarme à
cheval auto mitrailleuse le tout survolé
par un hélicoptère surveillant tout à
troupements suspecte aux abords des
arènes
la Réunion c'est néanmoins déroulée
normalement un point marqué par Georges
vanzeller et ses amis
comme autrefois il se retrouve et pas
seulement pour parler de la pluie et du
beau temps à la sortie de la messe
l'époque des silences prudents est
décidément révolu devant l'étranger on
ne se gêne plus pas besoin de forcer la
confidente le nouveau Portugal est
tourné en dérision avec ses institutions
son goût des réformes jugées inutiles et
des changements subis comme une
véritable chienlit
c'est un chaos c'est un anarchie
complète parce que vous savez on a fait
un espèce de
arachi national
et c'était le naufrage ce qui se passe à
l'instruction il a pas de professeur il
y a des professeurs ils disent le
ministère ils disent qu'il n'y a pas de
professeur mais on sait qu'il y a
professeur au chômage alors on comprend
pas les classes donnent pas l'abstention
des professeurs c'est énorme la qualité
de l'enseignement c'est affreux
il n'a plus d'histoire pour vous donner
un exemple il n'a plus d'histoire
Portugal maintenant on études l'histoire
fidèle Castries et de marcher tout
ça au lieu d'étudier des racines
historiques portugais on pourra vous
répondre que après 50 ans de salazarisme
il y a toujours 60 ou 70% d'analphabète
au Portugal non moi je ne crois pas
moi je figure 30 30% 30 à 40 %
pas plus que ça et vous trouvez que
c'est normal non non c'est pas normal et
on reproche ça mais il faut faire un
travail de base immédiat rapide n'est
pas au sujet de finale Castro et dans le
domaine économique
ça c'est le cas où ce qu'on prête
continue ça réaliste d'alièsk
l'inflation c'est 50% le chômage c'est
plus douce pour cent vous savez que nous
étions le troisième pays au monde avec
les réserves d'or maintenant c'est
presque fini ils ont tout englouti je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait de l'or
personne sait il y a un ministre je
crois ministre finances qui disent que
tu sais tout très bien que les choses
sont magnifiques et les résultats il n'y
a pas
d'après votre description
indiscutablement vous regrettez quand
même l'Ancien Régime
donc dans un cercle sort oui mais dans
le fond la question sociale progressive
non
vous vous sacrifieriez volontiers la
démocratie à l'efficacité
non parce que je crois que la démocratie
vraie la vraie démocratie c'est d'abord
efficacité
efficacité démocratie deux mots
apparemment inconciliables dans le
Portugal aujourd'hui Georges vanzeleer
et les siens n'ont que faire des jeux
politiques actuels avec Salazar
distillent ont travaillé et ont prospéré
dans le silence
or en ce pointant 76 le flot deloquence
est de polémique submergent le pays
recouvre les murs il se brise il est
vrai sur la prudence des hommes de la
lentejo la bataille de dimanche ça
allait dépasse un peu alors ils
attendent mis indifférent mis placide le
résultat de l'empoignade électorale
le temps il a fait assez froid comme
nous vous l'avions annoncé hier soir il
y a eu quelques faibles gelés matinales
dans la journée ça c'est un peu amélioré
mais la température a rarement dépassée
10 degrés sur la moitié nord et 14
degrés sur le sud demain le ciel sera
encore très nageuse de la Corse et de la
Provence au nord-est avec des pluies ou
des neiges en montagne des orages sur le
midi ou le mistral soufflera sur les
autres régions le temps sera variable
avec des averses près de la Manche et
sur les Pyrénées avec des éclaircies le
temps restera froid pour la saison avec
des gelées le matin pas trop fortes dieu
merci et les vents seront modernes voilà
ce soir c'est fini par Rouart qui non
pas en train de programme mais avant le
ciné-club nous présentera la dernière
édition de notre journal bonne soirée à
tous à lundi